hello welcome to another gamespot plays
reveille overwatch Eric Tay we're in the
closed beta amazing fun time yeah we
lucky few we band of heroes and we're
gonna try to jump in and basically play
this for 15 minutes and try and distill
down how good / watches into one game
which will largely not be up to us
because who knows what type of crazy
youtubers are gonna end up playing with
that's fine we got Annie Baumann on our
team also I feel like sometimes the
matches can go real quick yeah either
either you know you get rolled or maybe
you roll someone I lost a match in two
minutes yes we did not I did Oh God well
ago we at myself and Andy who's in our
party right now and we had some
absolutely spectacular games this
morning one of which went down to one of
the capture points went down to the last
like two seconds and we got us and
another one in which we lost in the last
four seconds geez yeah the central on
fox trot yeah there's definitely some
tense moments it's almost like it's like
when you're defending and it's a little
bit easier I feel like because you you
kind of like obviously you know where
they have to go and like since its your
game and its beta like I have to figure
their way out to how to get around and
stuff like that but people will figure
it out of course so top level for those
who don't know overwatch is basically a
game which if they're still down to the
most rudimentary genres you could say is
a first-person experience like a MOBA in
a way because it is a hero a game where
you're picking one of currently eighteen
different heroes which you can hot swap
in and out of during the game yep and
and then apart from that it's it's
similar enough to a sort of a team
fortress 2 you know asymmetric maps with
a bunch of sort of traditional game
types these are the various difference
heroes our team here is just me and Andy
we're probably gonna get pushed into
another game at once this roster fills
up and you've got offensive defensive as
sort of the tank ease and then your
support classes leave so here plays
music that heals people and make some
super fast and shields when he gets his
super for sure symetra here's got a
bunch of different like little turrets
and is able to create and she's able to
create the transporter chocolate
teleport okay yeah it's really handy
actually once you can kind of set that
up in the front lines it
we push the Gorton's the kind of like
yeah it's a flash to thing based yeah
the same kind of issue yep so every
character has you hit f1 you'll see the
the various skills they have at super
super varied so instead of everyone
having like left shift be a running and
mechanic for our good friend McCree here
it's a combat role for reaper he
basically turns into a wraith and walks
through yeah he's invulnerable and
torbjorn has got he's got a turret build
on his one so everyone has like a bunch
of different skills locked to their
ebook and cue button and then shift
bastions on my favor which will probably
play later and he turns he can repair
himself using e and he can basically
turn into a torus or walk around like a
real human boy with left shift and then
his alts which is the queue button
basically turns you into a roaming tank
nice i like that dude so let's see who's
gonna pick who I guess like I said we
were able to swap ash we want to as well
yeah during the matching you can have
multiple of like you can have to be
bashing for sure we wanted to yeah right
now I could be I could be Reaper here if
this guy as well so Andy's going with
tracer yep the superfast british lady
who can speed through time I'm gonna go
if he's doing that and we're defending
I'm gonna go Bastion yeah I feel like
you know depending on what side you're
playing you kind of favor certain heroes
a little bit more this in the early
going here because like you said you
know bashan is such a good defensive
type of hero where you can kind of you
know situate yourself on the capture
point that you know they're trying to
get to and just mowed them down ho down
he spends it takes a long time for him
to walk anywhere so I probably wouldn't
use him for offense because the front
lines are so far away yeah and so like I
said at the various different moves II
he can heal himself you can see in the
bottom right they have a really good job
of sort of telegraphing what the
different buttons are left chef you
straight up turns into a turret with a
shield nice and here you can basically
just drill people to this is reload time
is super fast as well so and i like this
guy lot so i'm gonna mosey on over nice
to defend to defend point a which is in
25 seconds so we'll see how you get a
lot of time to kind of like get the lay
of the land kind of get your team set up
the way you want to and also i think you
can you can even eat and repair while
your interment yeah
yeah like awesome so yes super favor of
mine so they gotta come around decide
I'm gonna set down relatively exposed
let's say here I want to be able to get
that window up there yeah exactly so the
window things too exposed but we'll see
what up yeah the window things also an
interesting kind of gameplay mechanic
because it kind of gets you to play
different heroes it's like Sir only
certain heroes can get to that we had a
flag ones mostly ax and like I think
hands-on might be able to wall run up
there and like Widowmaker can probably
oh nice shot 10 i reloaded probably the
wrong time it's fine you got Hank sarva
she said she's like it seemed like I
there I could just dump brands in there
though it's great i just love like
dumping dumping rant at yeah there's
loads of like cool combinations you can
do one for instance if torbjörn who's
the sort of turret making oh thanks
buddy at art making a dude was to put a
tart beside me i'd also be protecting
him with my shield yep which is
beneficial and there's also a chat wheel
which is in it now so i can say thank
you look like that the game goes fully
support voice chat as well yes the first
time Blizzard has had one in the game
why oh yeah I want to say I'm pretty
sure a lot of first yes first person
shooter yeah first action game since if
you can't starcraft ghost there's i'm
not sure i'm gonna be talking about
getting shot in a shop so i was gonna
bring that up actually so this is like
as an offensive player trying to get to
a capture point tracer is a very good
character to pick to try to get behind
enemy lines to kind of get some of you
guys responding so that their team can
push up its she's a real tough one she's
really good at getting bastion as well
and what i like is that I've tuned my
ear to the sound of her blinking
blinking yeah because by I'm constantly
getting dumped by them so as you can see
in the bottom my alters now available
which is fast turning a light kills me
yeah I got a bunch of kill so it's
pretty fast so hopefully I can get in
there we're gonna lose a so I'm gonna
hopefully get rid of
takes a second and then blasting Ohio so
this is your alt when you turn into tank
mode long almost damn it yeah it's
really show them better yes that's all
right i mean it is really hard to kind
of go against like three other people
when you kind of don't have a healer
which is why it's kind of important to
have a support player to be there to
back you up but often sitting really
good job there of kind of killing
everyone right so yeah you guys are all
back and then and then capturing it but
be is a really hard one to get so yeah
he is super hard is so it took them
awhile to get that one actually so
hopefully they won't be able to get
their tracer around here at 22 great day
I'll try and make all here we go koala
the british lady poke your head at ooh
there goes mercy yeah I can hear I can
irritate it up did you get a little time
gone down there as fair as a ultimate
which is a kind of like raining down
rockets from the sky yeah oh great job
she kind of got the the black hole type
move where she kind of vacuums everyone
in it's just unfortunate that there
wasn't anyone there to fall dude gotta
get rolling on this one
hey that was a fast one oh yeah that can
happen I'm gonna say my team suck Andy
ma'am and where you at bro what's going
on actually that kind of rucksack
because I want to show a different guard
in different mode of possible so here's
the play the game which was a I really
like this I feel like I really like this
because you can you can kick technically
get play of the game without actually
winning sometimes ya just from doing
something cool ok to me oh yeah and the
other thing is this is the score screen
and it doesn't actually show say you
know ok I got something at it good man I
can you can come in yourself and then
myself thirty-six percent of the team
damage thank you very much and yeah so
this is cool if you get five of these
then it gives you kind of a little well
done that you can't cash these in
anything or anything I heard like 10 it
gets crazy so like if you do really well
i know and i think that's a nice little
touch too because you know even though
you didn't win the opposite team can
kind of respect the fact like hey that
guy was pretty doing pretty well or your
team can be like yeah like i was doing
pretty well so you you know you always
come i left the party he's like I'm out
of here and stop saying overwatch who
knows what he's doing now yeah yeah so
overall it is a game that sort of tries
to reward you for not just kills yeah
it's the fair to say like they if you go
to the like we showed the score screen
here a second ago it doesn't just rank
people with kills debts Katy or any of
that stuff and it lets you know if
you're on fire which lets the other team
know as well if you're on fire which
basically means are you an influential
player and I could be editing from
taking damage to receiving to and
killing women as well yeah yeah yeah
just or having like a long life perhaps
and so we're on attack so let's show off
Farah which is kind of like she's kind
of the opposite end of the spectrum
because she's super mobile is a shift
shoots her up she's got this a little
rocket package in you can kind of
used to rain down liquid hell there's a
cool down on the the jump there and but
I got it back again so it's a 10-second
soon so I also want to bring up a good
point to its that you know we are
playing the beta one of course and you
when we played it originally the first
time the way the the matches worked out
actually was that you know after you
played one side you'd play the other so
that it would be fair yes so like in the
last I'm kind of curious to see when
that kind of comes back so that you can
kind of get your revenge if you give
loose or something or if it's close
because it becomes a time-based yeah for
sure yeah cuz then it's like who can do
a faster coming right yeah they've
various Reapers there I hate this guy
okay really strong i'll close he's got
the dual shotguns i can do some have if
anyone's around that was mercy i think
she just like left you don't really yes
she's healing the tank was yeah it's
probably got over there but i think
we're probably jumping a little bit too
quick into that area yeah we don't have
any more i like to run in and just cause
havoc because it sort of scrambles the
team a little bit like kill this dude oh
my god double here oh why'd you got wide
you gotta say that man i don't know i
like kingston things i should have shown
that i did i think that shot was
probably charged up some of the Slifer
shots can be charged next I for the sake
of fun mix it up a little bit and we got
any favorites I should probably do um
watching once you try drunk rat a little
bit he's an interesting one he's a
little bit newer I've never seen him he
has like super nasal hunter yeah he's
got grenade launcher his left shift is
this mine which you can then basically
blow off the left click which is pretty
good five second cooldown on that one e
is a like a I guess I'm like a bear trap
kind of thing it's pretty big though so
if any of the end we run over that one
and we're really [ __ ] them up
so I think I got him on them almost in a
fair job and it's also key if you do
yeah if you do see like mercy or
something like that you definitely want
to take her out as soon as possible
because she's healing their tanks or
they're seeing other dps and that's
gonna cause a lot of problems I
accidentally threw that [ __ ] mine
onto the side of the tub telephone pole
surfer can work out sometimes you never
know yeah I got sick him two walls
pretty cool yeah actually what happened
to me last night was a junk rat was
pretty much targeting me the whole game
when I was mercy every time he got his
ultimate which is kind of like this
remote control uh like drone mine yeah
super cool yeah he was basically
targeting me only with that all right i
was super annoying because he knew i was
healing the tank and he learned routines
hahahaha flank [ __ ] great work
oh nice and we got all right right here
in store in here yeah he got inside the
bubble yeah oh I'm providing a fight
they got revised alright we're back in
come on folks let's capture this bad boy
yeah so I gotta throw my little mine
over there may be as well just double
check if anyone comes over but I think
we got it see the little Frankie yeah so
that's the best thing about this game is
that it's like it's the way in which
it's different to games like team
fortress which I love is that this game
is not just about the gunplay it's very
much about gunplay but it's also like
very much focused on tactics I won't
wanna stare was tactic because my all
this is nice
surprised how I got killed by my Brooke
Widowmaker I was on fire there see on
the me enforce and rock cooling on this
team we're doing real good and the other
team can see that as well yeah and I
think it's also nice because it can it
gives you different playstyles you know
like maybe you really like being a
support maybe you're like healing or
maybe you like being a tank and being on
the front line so you know it caters to
a lot of different people the game one
we're playing now is halo hey there's a
call hello yep it's called yeah it's
basically in this was anyone who play
team fortress 2 his dick was hold i
would say lodash but that's a different
thing it's something similar I the names
it's the more you push the train in Team
Fortress it's basically the same thing
that's what we the one maybe little
criticism might have of overwatch at
least so far and maybe criticism is a
bit too strong and is that many most of
the game was are very traditional there
you played a lot of them in other games
before it's just point capture stuff and
things like that but I certainly think
that the variety and the hero of
themselves is yeah I made this game it
makes up for it you know that's
definitely like for now kind of
situation we don't know like because
this is kind of keeps it simple for
people to just understand and play the
characters and kind of yeah more use of
that and then there might be trickier
stuff in future once you try someone
else yeah I showed that was a bad
matchup there to be stuck with yeah it's
a bummer out against again sir is
tracy's tracers not particularly good
particularly good either all right let's
mix it up which would be I'd be a tanker
is more baby yeah go for one of the big
boys yeah let's see how about wednesday
sure he's a fun one yeah he's got this
big dumb gone which I highly ever play
would actually charges up pretty good
yeah I played against a really good
Winston yesterday uh you know he would
use his barrier protector really well
they can't really do anything to you
unless they're inside the bubble or
they'd break the bubble Master Chief
bubble shield kind of thing yes so then
this girl jumbo ago yeah so then what he
would do is he would be near health
packs and then he would drop his shield
and then wait for his like jump away
cool down to come up and then he's like
get away it's alright he thought bus oh
the other Winston's going crazy
all right we got the bastion go go go so
that bats bubble shield can very easily
go on top of this train as well I
believe hi I believe you correct all
right we got one they're gonna jump over
this side blanka's ass put another
shield down it's working don't forget
got melee to do his one's good actually
as well which is it's kind of hard to
get to one thing I've feel sometimes I
just like the meal blankie blankie than
expected I was again a little bit too
yeah meet you there it's okay I mean
it's just kind of slowly where they get
respawn but at the same time you're
pushing them back to sit and it kind of
helps the team out let's mix it up again
show me doing this for the sake of the
day now but hey we're doing it for the
sake of the people exactly do should we
do try sir yeah we should pretty popular
I'm not sure if she's a good selection
this one what we'll do it anyway well
you can find you love flanking right so
thank you thank you right here so her
ones are she blinks with shift she has a
pulse bomb as well and then oh whoa whoa
it's good let's get that one by shift
shift shift and then you can go
backwards by pressing e and you're
getting your life back yes you getting
your life back and you also go backwards
yeah so it's pretty pretty good at sex
yes I'm gonna do this this and then get
the photo she's going yeah ganache haha
totally [ __ ] its I cool down on my
heroine wasn't back yet so i just threw
myself into it's a balancing right
that's a longer cool down as it should
be yeah you know so um got it my fault
she definitely is a high-risk
high-reward but you know you can figure
her out and get her down she's just so
good for getting behind enemy lines and
kind of just rattling people trying to
like set up there static defence it's
like when you were bashing she she
totally got behind you and by the time
you kind of noticed it was hard to react
hey gosh he's he at the seabed one way
and then the other way mm-hmm every
choice she has super low health which is
problematic um one of my favorite things
to do with her is kill this guy
oh [ __ ] that soldier 76 that's like the
pretty standard kind of like here's your
FPS normal dude yeah here's call of duty
man has left his Ron ability which you
know for some people is you know raped
walk for instance here where I can like
walk through and then I'd be
invulnerable his one is just run my Call
of Duty like it's but so he's kind of
easy that way all right range any shot
ya to god I love dumps commits my
favorite game you know what's funny i
was watching a guy reloaded and then
they're just stay on the floor for a sec
yeah and then they disappear it's a
couple of them it just stay there you
just got a bunch of shotguns in his
pockets somehow okay we're moving again
we're moving yeah no thanks to me
because I've been [ __ ] tired whole
time they're Reinhard's doing some good
work gone over here a little bit so he
can do a kind of a yeah so that's like a
little teleport type move and the thing
is as it as the enemy you can actually
see where he's gonna go so that's why
it's a little risky to as well cuz I got
to find a ham sit I've got a race walk
out of there so don't get killed we're
the healing stuff as well as is for
everyone and it shows the cool down so
I'm gonna go cause once you know I
Mercy's there boy all right let's get
going alright we're almost up to
checkpoint all right we got it we got it
little rate grateful walk situation I
have to help my buddy out here I am his
one his all this pretty super special
didn't see me [ __ ] all right I
the heel maybe gotta race walk out of
there so they don't eat me up thank you
for the heel yeah all teamwork right
mm-hmm of course I get my ass up there
hopefully nobody noticed this [ __ ] I
hate that so that's a bastion and oh so
I really need to probably shouldn't be
killing this guy really yeah but you're
kind of messing with them they don't
know where you're at what's beautiful on
the studies yeah Mercy's helping like
gettin raped walk through this guy
although i think i need to reload which
is a problem that's fine alright just
let going go go on kids all right let me
transport behind these guys for those
seconds oh yeah Scotty's got results I'm
gonna rape to walk in that situation
making me waste his odds completely yes
it's a game work dammit i had mine as
well almost but it is a game that will
reward your skill as you get over time
and it's one of those games that's easy
to get into too yeah well which is the
the fun part of it i think some
characters are more difficult to use
than others i think it's fair to say and
I think that's totally phrase and like
for instance trace there's kind of an
easy one to get into quickly but
difficult to master there's one tank in
this I forget her name but she's super
specific issues she's quite tricky yeah
Mikey's ARMA that is a body the right
yes yeah oh yeah he's a crazy thing
where she has this shield they're
watching us watch it i love this i love
my old watches
oh you got 10 she's got two and hang out
10 just got girl I've day you gotta ride
awesome all in all though probably not
very well no I think you needed to do
that because you guys are about to you
guys got to escort it you got 10 seconds
and that revived was so clutch we do it
yo what I'll take it baby I let's revive
let's revive st that's it I gotta let
the team down there sick revive cool we
want it raccoon his widow maker was our
play they play the game of our playmaker
she's an interesting one like cuz I once
you hold it down long enough I think
it's kind of auto targets when it kind
of the diamond I think it charges all
good it's super powerful anyway it's
definitely the bug and there we go I got
here no no sign in fairness I was
changing across at every two sec yeah
and that's our watch I'm gonna give mine
to wreck removal that's overwatch yeah
the beta is currently closed make sure
you opt-in on battlenet though because
they're going to be doing open weekends
for everyone else to get involved I
think this game is super good I think
it's gonna be a big player in the first
person you think so I think Sam I think
we're kind of entering this territory of
like I think this is the new thing like
you have a team based shooter and this
one so far from the few that i played is
the one that stands out the most and you
know it has the pedigree of like a big
company that's kind of knows how to make
games so I'm excited cool thanks for
watching case I'll plays folks more
coverage of this and many other video
games stay tuned to gamespot com